Hi, in this video we're going to look at scoping the effort to audit a website.
Before you start testing, it's useful to estimate how much time and effort will be required to adequately audit the target website.
Factors that will affect this are the number of dynamic URLs, how many parameters each URL contains,
and the nature and complexity of the website functionality.
In most cases, dynamic URLs take more effort to audit than static URLs.
The effort increases if the website contains more parameters.
This information can also help you work out the best places to start looking for vulnerabilities.
You need to use your own judgement to determine the scope of the audit.
But how can Burp help?
You can follow along with this process using GinandJuice.shop, our deliberately vulnerable demonstration website.
First of all, you'll need to map the website.
We have separate tutorials on this if you'd like to find out more.
Once the site has been mapped, you can start by using the target analyzer to give you an idea of the size and complexity of the target.
This tool will only analyze content you have mapped.
To use it, go to the target site map tab.
Right click on the site you've mapped.
Select engagement tools.
Analyze target.
You can then select dynamic URLs or static URLs to see more information about the target.
URLs are classified as static if they don't accept any parameters in the URL or request body.
However, responses may still be dynamically generated by the application.
On the parameters tab, if you select a parameter, Burp will show a list of all the URLs that contain the parameter.
If you select the URL, you can see the full request and response.
You can also use the site map to assess the contents of the website.
In the site map, you can identify dynamic URLs by looking for the parameter tree view icon.
You can also identify URLs with issues by looking for colored circles next to the tree view icons.
Items in the site map can be selected to view the requests and responses.
Finally, you can also make use of the live audit function within Burp.
On the dashboard, in the Issue Activity window, you can look for information that suggests your audit will require more effort.
For example, the live audit may flag the presence of a file upload function, which will take more effort to test due to the hidden complexity.
The link is in the description.